bonjour nous sommes le jeudi 9 avril
merci de nous retrouver pour un nouveau
numéro de Philippo votre émission qui
revient sur l'actualité économique
locale on commence aussi avec les titres
de cette édition
dans notre
semaine nous parlerons de vdcom qui fête
ses 1 an à l'Institut de Versailles donc
cette fête c'est un an nous parlerons
également du métier de gemmologue un
métier d'art d'artisanat de luxe et
enfin nous parlerons aussi des jobs
d'été qui se multiplient en ce moment
c'est l'occasion pour tous les étudiants
de trouver un job pour cet été
et notre cas sera notre entretien pardon
sera également consacré au job d'été
pour certains étudiants pas de répit
sont à peine en vacances et c'est déjà
le moment de trouver un travail pour
payer leurs vacances étoffer leur CV ou
découvrir d'autres horizons nous en
parlerons avec mes deux invités
lucilière indivine Information Jeunesse
et Fabienne lafavre de la maison de la
jeunesse et de la culture de Rambouillet
mais avant cela passe en revue
l'actualité économique de la semaine
ressemblera à quoi ressemblera le
véhicule de demain dans les Yvelines à
Versailles un institut irréfléchit
depuis un anvd comme regroupe chercheur
grandes entreprises et automobile ainsi
que pmech il vient de fêter c'est un an
l'occasion de faire le point sur son
action sur place Catherine vulado et
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
cette voiture électrique conduite par
Anne-Charlotte Nico à une particularité
elle peut aussi se conduire sans
chauffeur un véhicule totalement
automatisé bourré de capteurs qui
prennent tout en charge à la place du
conducteur un peu à l'image d'un être
humain la voiture pour conduire a besoin
de percevoir son environnement donc ce
sont les capteurs de perception qui joue
ce rôle là donc celle-ci a une vision à
360 degrés afin de
minimiser le risque d'anglement voire
même supprimer complètement
elle a besoin également de se localiser
donc ce sont le but des capteurs de
localisation puisque vous avez besoin de
savoir où vous êtes et quel est
l'environnement autour de vous et enfin
elle doit prendre des décisions donc ce
qu'on appelle le module de supervision
ce sont toute l'intelligence embarquée
et tout le cœur de nos algorithmes ce
véhicule prototype est l'une des grandes
fiertés de vdcom il est testé sur les
pistes de satori l'Institut de
transition énergétique a été lancée il y
a un an il travaille sur toutes les
questions de mobilité d'électrification
d'automatisation et de connectivité des
voitures du futur on a les grandes
entreprises de l'automobile française
qui sont fondateurs de vdcom des grands
instituts de recherche et puis également
des PME et bientôt des startups donc
c'est un écosystème de près de 40
membres qui travaillent ensemble tous
les jours
un mariage entre secteur public et privé
entre petites et grandes entreprises
entre chercheurs et ingénieurs qui
portent ces fruits aujourd'hui
l'Institut emploi un peu moins de 100
personnes ils seront plus de 150 à la
fin de l'année et il est prévu encore
une centaine d'embauches d'ici 2016 pour
fonctionner les décom qui fait partie du
pays le plan d'investissement d'avenir
dispose d'un budget de 19 millions
d'euros ce budget est en croissance donc
sur trois ans et l'ensemble de vdcom est
financé à 10 ans pour globalement une
centaine de millions d'euros quand
l'État met un les industriels mettent un
ça c'est le principe de base du
financement de vdcom reste une
interrogation à quand une voiture sans
conducteur sur route pour l'heure c'est
interdit en France et en Europe seul
l'état du Nevada aux États-Unis a donné
cette autorisation pour la Google Car
mais l'avenir s'annonce radio pour
vedécom en octobre prochain la Ville de
Bordeaux va accueillir le Congrès
mondial des systèmes automatisés et les
responsables en sont persuadés les
derniers leviers lég islatifs devraient
se lever en attendant vdcom travail
également sur un pôle d'excellence qui
ouvrira la fin de l'année à sa Tori pour
préparer cette fois les moteurs
électriques de demain
et nous continuons à parler transports
cette semaine la SNCF a présenté ses
projets 2015 pour le Transilien objectif
dans les Yvelines des ongorger les trois
lignes qui desservent Versailles 50 ans
en Yvelines et Versailles la c'est la
haine et la u mais également donné un
coup de jeune aux infrastructures
vieillissantes un reportage de Mélanie
poquet Yolaine Torres et William hell
retard à répétition RAM saturé
infrastructures obsolète le Transilien
iblinois est dans la ligne de mire des
usagers conscient des difficultés
Transilien SNCF a engagé des études et
discussions pour analyser ces
difficultés notamment sur la ligne L
avec le tronçon par Riverside il y a
deux problèmes aujourd'hui un la ligne
est saturée c'est à dire que alors
qu'elle fonctionnait très très bien il y
a quelques années le fait qui est de
plus en plus de voyageurs fait que les
temps d'attente en gare montée des
centres sont de plus en plus importants
et donc un effet boule de neige les
trains prennent depuis plus de retard en
collaboration avec l'association plus de
trains pour la défense Transilien a
élaboré un nouveau plan de transport
comprenant une meilleure répartition des
trains il sera mis en oeuvre le 13
décembre de cette année autre sujet
d'amélioration la ligne du RER C pour
laquelle plus d'un milliard d'euros de
travaux sont engagés jusqu'en 2020 cette
ligne souffre particulièrement de
l'ancienneté de ses infrastructures la
ligne C elle a une infrastructure
notamment ancienne elle a une caténaire
qui a plus de 95 ans et donc il faut la
rénover il faut rénover également les
rails dans le tronçon central et ce sont
des travaux qu'on engage à partir de
2015 dernière annonce qui concerne aussi
les Yvelines noires le forfait toute
zone votée en décembre 2014 avec un
tarif unique de 70 €. il entrera en
vigueur le premier septembre prochain
bientôt une nouvelle monnaie pour le
parc national de Chevreuse en tout cas
le projet est lancé dans le cadre d'un
appel à projet de la région
Île-de-France sur des fonds européens le
parc national de Chevreuse pourrait
lancer sa propre monnaie en parallèle de
l'euro bien sûr ce projet a pour but de
favoriser l'économie locale et de
développer les services et circuits
courts locaux écouter les précisions de
Olivier songe chargé de mission au sein
du parc naturel régional
dans la pratique ça fonctionnerait avec
un système de conversion pour les les
adhérents pour les habitants ou les
commerçants qui souhaitent utiliser la
monnaie locale donc les gens
changeraient directement leurs euros en
monnaie locale complémentaire et ensuite
ça fonctionnerait exactement comme
l'Euro avec des échanges de caisse des
échanges de monnaie ça peut aussi
fonctionner avec une carte type carte
bleue spécifique mais spécialement dédié
à la monnaie locale
pour créer cette monnaie un budget
d'environ 100000 euros est nécessaire
d'ici un mois le Parc Naturel Régional
devrait recevoir une réponse et savoir
si le projet est accepté nous vous
tiendrons au courant il est maintenant
de parler job étudiant c'est l'heure de
notre entretien de la semaine
et en plateau avec moi cette semaine
pour parler de job étudiant donc Lucile
Guérin divine informations jeunesse
bonjour
que de la maison de la jeunesse et de la
culture de Rambouillet donc nous allons
parler avec vous deux de travail
saisonnier pour les étudiants vous
connaissez bien cette problématique car
toutes les deux vous orientez vous aider
les jeunes dans justement cette
problématique et dans leurs recherches
mais avant d'en discuter je vous propose
de regarder un reportage un forum sur
les jobs d'été a été organisé ce
mercredi au Centre Ariane de
Vélizy-Villacoublay plus de 100 jeunes
sont venus armer de leur CV afin de
décrocher peut-être le job étudiant de
leur été je vous propose de regarder ce
reportage signé Michael el midoro
William l et Mathilde Caberg
Clément a 20 ans il est venu chercher
son premier job d'été je cherche juste à
travailler parce que j'ai beaucoup de
temps libre avant d'avoir ma reprise
d'études là j'ai envie de le compléter
un peu un rendez-vous annuel très
attendu par tous les étudiants du
département le forum sur les jobs d'été
organisés par Yvelines informations
jeunesse propose une centaine d'offres
d'emplois on a une dizaine de recruteurs
présents l'idée c'est que justement il y
a différents secteurs d'activités qui
soient représentés pour que chaque jeune
puisse s'y retrouver de la grande
distribution au cueillette à l'aide à la
personne donc c'est assez varié il faut
aussi bien sûr que ce soit accessible
puisque qui dit jeune dit forcément pas
beaucoup d'expérience professionnelles
au total l'événement attiré plus de 500
étudiants des Yvelines ils ont pu
déposer cette occasion leur CV leur
lettre de motivation au recruteur je ne
sorte pour chercher du travail
saisonnier quoi
gagner un peu ma vie
être un peu plus autonome l'accueil il
est très bien oui on est bien j'ai reçu
les personnes sont super gentils
franchement c'est bien c'est une bonne
idée pour trouver un job facilement
et trouve original l'association
agricole annefa tenait un stand la
structure propose des jobs d'été dans
l'agriculture partout en France ce sont
des postes de cue
illette vendant
ou si moisson donc il y a une variété de
métiers et importantes en agriculture il
travaille le matin bien sûr mais en fin
d'après-midi les soirées sont libres et
ils peuvent faire la fête s'ils sont
capables de se lever le matin bien
évidemment parce que les exploitants
agricoles veulent que leurs salariés
soit dans les champs le matin pour
ramasser et cueillir les fruits et
légumes ça fait une expérience
complètement différente de ce qu'on fait
de ce qu'on apprend vraiment dans la
campagne et puis en plus c'est enfin ça
peut faire un bon job d'été travail à
l'extérieur tout ça si vous avez manqué
ce forum job d'été à Vélizy pas de
panique vous pouvez toujours demander
des renseignements dans les bureaux
Information Jeunesse du département
alors nous sommes au mois d'avril l'été
c'est quand même dans plusieurs mois
c'est pas tout de suite je me demandais
les cigarettes est-ce que voilà c'est
vraiment le moment de commencer la dès
le mois d'avril pour trouver un job
étudiant
parce qu'après il sera trop tard
malheureusement les entreprises ont déjà
fait leur recrutement ont déjà trouvé
tous les effectifs donc c'est maintenant
qu'il faut s'en préoccuper déjà avoir
préparé son CV ça l'aide de motivation
et puis pas hésiter à nous solliciter
réseaux information jeunesse pour avoir
des pistes pour trouver un job d'été ça
vient de lavable on a vu le sujet on a
vu plusieurs donc étudiants plusieurs
jeunes voilà interagir et être à la
recherche d'un job étudiants ce qu'ils
avaient la bonne attitude de ce qu'on a
vu je sais pas qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé ils ont une bonne attitude l'idée
c'est effectivement de se rendre sur les
forums avec en CV si possible l'avoir
montré en professionnel avant de d'être
habillé convenablement et puis de
multiplier les tentatives pour avoir une
chance de trouver un emploi on a vu je
crois dans le reportage que certains
avaient été accompagnés leurs parents
est-ce que c'est nécessaire mais parfois
pour les mineurs je pense notamment oui
on s'ap énormément de parents qui
accompagnent les jeunes dont les invite
plutôt à faire la démarche au sol et de
laisser les parents à l'entrée du forum
par exemple pour montrer vraiment une
démarche plus active du jeûne justement
si on parle des mineurs est-ce que les
mineurs peuvent également travailler ce
que c'est plus compliqué sur quel point
il faut peut-être faire attention aussi
à partir de 16 ans un mineur peut
travailler après on le cache pas que ça
va être un petit peu plus difficile de
trouver un job d'été parce que la
concurrence est rude il y a pas de temps
de jobs que ça pour voir quand on est
mineure ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il
va falloir une autorisation parentale
pour pouvoir travailler bon ça
normalement ils ont pas trop de mal à
l'obtenir et puis après au niveau de la
législation il y a des choses qui
diffèrent donc pour un employeur c'est
un petit peu plus contraignant
par exemple il faut un temps de travail
un petit peu moins
qui peut être intéressant de savoir
c'est qu'il y a certains secteurs qui
vont recruter en priorité plus
facilement en tout cas les mineurs
service à la personne tout ce qui va
être garde d'enfant
dans l'animation
et justement après il faut faire
attention quand on postule un job d'été
je pense notamment à la législation sur
quel point il faut être vraiment très
très voilà très très
attentionné justement pour pas nous
faire d'erreur dans son contrat qu'on
signe
de bien bien vérifier que l'entreprise
est sérieux ce que le contrat de travail
voilà est signé entre le jeûne et
l'entreprise de jamais commencer un job
d'été sans avoir signé de contrat de
travail ça c'est en quelque sorte la
base ce sont en général des CD deux mois
ou c'est un peu plus ça peut être moins
il y a certaines entreprises qui vont
chercher
deux semaines mais c'est vrai que être
disponible au moins un mois c'est la
base et justement au niveau de
l'encadémie peut-être des horaires à ne
pas dépasser c'est 35 heures par semaine
pour des mineurs ce sera moins mais
voilà c'est la base légale et donc voilà
on propose des CDD pour les gens qui
dirigent vers l'animation parce que
justement c'est un secteur qui emploie
pas mal de jeunes ça se passe comment
dans ce cas là c'est la même le même
type de
il va y avoir différents types de
contrats selon s'ils sont des structures
de jours ou en interne avec donc des
séjours à l'étranger ou en itinérance
généralement ce sont des tarifs
journaliers donc on est on parle pas en
tarif horaire mais on t'arrive jour
dans le dans le reportage on a vu qu'il
y avait beaucoup de enfin que justement
l'agriculture la cueillette ça pourrait
être un secteur qui emploie parce que
c'est vrai parce que c'est pas forcément
voilà le domaine auquel on pense qu'on
parle du job d'été en fait oui c'est
selon les régions c'est plus ou moins
important mais effectivement ça fait
partie des grandes domaines qui emploi
l'été des étudiants des jeunes et du
coup il faut être un petit peu averti
quand même pour y aller tout le monde
peut y aller facilement parce que il y a
des conditions de travail un petit peu
difficiles quand même il faut savoir que
voilà ça va pas être ça va pas être
évident travailler voilà en plein soleil
parfois s'il fait beau ça peut être
contraignant et après c'est des c'est
des job étudiants qui sont assez
sympathiques et puis comme disait la
dame dans le reportage de la néfa voilà
ça permet de d'avoir un petit job et
puis de pouvoir profiter de la région
dans laquelle on sera voilà est-ce qu'il
faut viser plutôt dans son secteur par
exemple dans ses études si on fait des
études de communication peut-être
trouver un job d'été en rapport avec la
communication ou justement ça va être
plus compliqué il faut vraiment viser
peut-être un secteur qui emploie plus
même si ça correspond pas du tout à à
son parcours professionnel qu'on vise je
dirais qu'en s'y prenant suffisamment en
avance on peut déjà commencer à regarder
dans le secteur dans lequel on évolue
dans le cadre de ses études après si on
voit que c'est fermé qu'on a pas
forcément de réponse de pas éviter de
pas hésiter à justement étendre sa
recherche à d'autres secteurs
l'animation
l'aide à la personne travailler dans le
commerce par exemple il y a pas mal de
propositions
voilà de montrer qu'on est motivé et
est-ce que vous pouvez me donner
peut-être une petite fourchette de
salaire qu'on peut espérer en étant
jeune en travaillant je sais pas
peut-être le plus gros salaires qu'on
puisse se faire en job saisonnier on va
souvent le SMIC qui apparaît sur les
offres
c'est le mieux qu'on puisse espérer où
je sais pas peut-être en restauration où
là peut-être avec les combats ou tu as
des primes d'objectif selon les emplois
mais c'est vrai que souvent la référence
reste le SMIC vous vous conseillez aux
jeunes d'aller plutôt vers quel secteur
les opportunités qui se présentent à eux
surtout de pas se fermer je pense que
c'est le plus important c'est de rester
ouvert toutes les opportunités qui
peuvent avoir
difficiles de trouver voilà un job
saisonnier c'est de plus en plus
difficile ou ça a pas vraiment d'impact
en fait non on se rend compte depuis
quelques années qu'on organise des
forums job d'été que quand même ça a
tendance un petit peu à devenir plus
difficile
parce que la concurrence est là les
entreprises aussi s'organisent
différemment plus de turn over à
l'intérieur de leur entreprise et du
coup il y a moins de place pour les
jeunes qui recherchent des jobs jobs
d'été
c'est d'autant plus difficile qu'on a un
peu isolé on est en fin de vie
départements on a moins de commerces on
a moins de temps de gros centres
commerciaux du coup c'est pas évident de
mobiliser des recruteurs et je pense
maintenant à la prochaine des soldes
d'été peut-être que là il y a je sais
pas il faut c'est ça vaut toujours le
coup peut-être de déposer un CV
oui de faire la tournée des magasins de
se présenter directement dans les
boutiques ou sur les entreprises
sinon je voulais parler aussi du
volontariat du Service volontaire
européen est-ce que c'est aussi un bon
moyen d'étoffer son CV peut-être ou de
gagner de l'argent mais si c'est
bénévolat peut-être un peu moins oui ça
peut être une bonne une bonne occasion
de se faire en plus une expérience à
l'étranger
d'améliorer son niveau de langue par
exemple donc le Service volontaire
européen ça peut être une bonne une
bonne initiative après au niveau votre
faut arriver à trouver une une mission
qui dure pendant l'été parce que ça
parfois le Service volontaire européen
peut être sur plus plus long terme
comment ça se passe un petit peu quand
on fait sa démarche qu'on veut justement
faire son Service volontaire européen
alors là il faut s'adresser en fait à
une structure d'envoi donc là on peut
renseigner dans les structures
information jeunesse on n'est pas toute
structure d'envoi mais on peut
renseigner on a un carnet d'adresses
avec voilà les structures d'envoies
qu'elles les jeunes peuvent s'adresser
parce que il y a tout un dossier à
prévoir il faut trouver une mission
dans le pays de son choix voilà donc
faut s'y prendre en avance c'est comme
pour les jobs d'été de pas hésiter à s'y
prendre
ça vienne là-bas je voulais également
qu'on parle des chantiers bénévoles si
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
parce que finalement c'est une
initiative qui est très peu connue donc
ce sont des missions que l'on propose
soit des ados soit des adultes qu'on
peut partir en chantier à partir de 14
ou 15 ans selon les organismes on part
pour deux trois semaines en France ou à
l'étranger donc ce sont des missions de
d'animation socio-culturelle de
rénovation autour de l'environnement et
c'est vrai que pour des mineurs ça peut
être une première expérience après à
mettre en valeur dans un CV pour
justement à valoriser pour un premier CV
après à 18 ans pour la première
recherche d'emploi ça donc le chantier
le service volontariat européen c'est
vraiment un vrai bonus sur le CV c'est
peut-être mieux de faire ça que de
travailler pendant peut-être un job qui
est moins intéressant enfin qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez ça peut surtout être
une opportunité pour les jeunes qui
trouvent pas un job forcément rémunéré
et du coup de partir à l'étranger ou en
chantier jeune bénévole
c'est sûr que la finalité n'est pas la
même étant donné qu'on va pas gagner
d'argent en tant que bénévole ou
volontaire donc pour quelqu'un qui n'a
pas trouvé un emploi ça peut être une
solution effectivement de valoriser de
remplir son CV quel conseil en fait vous
donneriez voilà à des jeunes qui veulent
soit postuler dans tes boutiques dans
des entreprises ou justement pour les
forums les derniers salons qu'il y a vu
que apparemment il y en a encore très
peu avant cet été oui il y en a un
dernier qui va avoir lieu sur Poissy
samedi prochain
de pas hésiter voilà à continuer ses
candidatures et puis à venir dans les
réseaux information jeunesse pour se
faire aider qu'on puisse leur donner
voilà de la documentation et puis des
conseils de dernière minute
une autre une autre un autre petit
conseil je sais pas sur la tenue
vestimentaire par exemple
sur lequel on postule et puis
effectivement de multiplier les
démarches très bien il est merci lucide
Guérin et Fabienne Laval d'être venu sur
notre plateau pour nous donner tous ces
conseils un dernier mot sur l'emploi
saisonnier et les jeunes c'est tout de
suite avec le chiffre de la semaine
74% des jeunes de plus de 18 ans ont
déjà effectué un job d'été selon une
étude OpinionWay 57% auraient même déjà
travaillé avant leur 18 ans la grande
majorité des jeunes interrogés explique
ce choix par une volonté de gagner de
l'argent mais aussi de se confronter au
monde du travail et de découvrir les
problématiques liées à la vraie vie en
entreprise
nous allons continuer de parler des
jeunes et de l'entreprise regarder
l'entrepreneur de la semaine c'est tout
de suite
et cette semaine nous avons rencontré
deux jeunes entrepreneurs yvelinois
installés à Maurepas l'année dernière
Vincent Marsat travaillait sur son
prototype de machine produisant des
hologrammes interactifs il vient de
s'associer avec Friedrich Chauvet pour
le commercialiser l'arc c'est le nom de
cette invention ils ont accepté de nous
la faire découvrir des images signées
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude roman respini
pour le montage
ils ont 25 et 26 ans Vincent et
Friedrich sont tous deux yvelinois le
premier est architecte freelance il est
à l'origine de l'hologramme interactif
le second est à la tête de la startup
scrutique qui développe des hologrammes
et des sites web de leur rencontre est
née la commercialisation d'Arc une idée
tout droit sortie de l'imagination de
Vincent à la base en fait ça part d'un
pari un pari d'un ami qui me disait
qu'il m'a montré ça en fait sur Internet
et qui me disait je parie que tu
arriveras jamais à le faire donc on l'a
fait avec du carton en fait simplement
du carton quelques bouts de plastique et
on est arrivé à faire quelque chose
comme ça sur un écran c'est 10000
pourquoi pas mettre nos maquettes à
l'intérieur en fait puis on s'agirait
dans notre esprit puis d'un coup enfin
moi j'ai commencé à travailler dessus et
à me dire mais je vais mettre mes
maquettes à l'intérieur mélange
d'innovation et de système préexistants
la pyramide holographique permet grâce
au codage de projeter différentes
maquettes en trois dimensions n'importe
qui peut alors interagir avec l'objet à
l'aide de ses mains en fait c'est un
monde 3D à l'intérieur de ce monde là on
a donc on a la 3D qu'on demande ou alors
quelque chose qui est numérisé
c'est-à-dire un bouquin par exemple
comme vous l'avez vu ici
donc à l'intérieur de ce monde là
ensuite il prend les différentes phases
d'une 3D et on va les afficher à l'écran
et c'est différentes phases vont être
ensuite refléter sur la pyramide ensuite
l'ordinateur lui tout ce qu'il fait bah
si gère la 3D et autres il gère ensuite
les interactions qu'on va le demander
grâce aux détecteur de mouvement 5 ans
de travail est près de 3500 euros ont
été nécessaires à Vincent pour élaborer
l'arc déjà testé en Corée du Sud son
hologramme a été utilisé par des musées
ou lors d'événements artistiques
aujourd'hui les deux entrepreneurs
veulent mettre les capacités de
l'invention au service de professionnels
nous on va plus s'orienter sur les
entreprises qui ont besoin par exemple
des cabinets d'architecture qui cabinets
d'architecture fabriquent une maquette à
chaque fois qu'ils ont un projet et ben
là en l'occurrence il a pas besoin de
refaire sa maquette il lance le fichier
directement et là en libre consultation
on continue et plusieurs architectes
peuvent interagir dessus avec l'essor
des imprimantes 3D les deux jeunes
entrepreneurs ont en tête des idées
compatibles avec leur invention
fabriquer et à la commande le logiciel
art qui a été prévu pour être compatible
avec absolument tous les programmes donc
tout n'importe quel logiciel n'importe
quel périphérique qui se branche dessus
et préparé à être compatible sur le
programme quand on passe dessus et nous
on arrive là-dessus en fait on supprime
la souris le clavier et l'écran pour que
vous puissiez modéliser vous-même à la
main propre vous racheter un art qu'il
faut débourser environ 2000 euros
l'objectif pour les deux entrepreneurs
et de vendre suffisamment de machines
pour réinvestir et améliorer ses
performances d'autres utilisations de
l'ARC sont encore à l'étude le
hologramme interactif pourrait un jour
se retrouver dans les hôpitaux et servir
à des fins médicales
et maintenant nous allons parler bijoux
et pierre précieuses avec le métier de
la semaine c'est tout de suite
et cette semaine nous nous intéressons à
un métier rare un métier précieux celui
de gemmologue à Versailles Caroline
mahymologue et créatrice de bijoux nous
a ouvert les portes de son atelier
regardez ce reportage réalisé avec
Patrick smud et Romain ruspini
je regarde le rayon lumineux d'une
pierre
j'évalue la lumière qui va passer à
l'intérieur et en fait ensuite on sait
exactement à combien il se situe pour
pouvoir vous dire que c'est un spinel
synthétique un 725 et absolument pas mis
une topaze ni une aigue-marine c'est un
faux c'est une synthèse rien n'échappe à
l'oeil averti de Caroline Mahi repérez
les gemmes d'exception ou trouver leurs
défauts c'est le quotidien de cette
versaillaise antiquaire devenu
gemmologue elle étudie choisit et achète
des pierres précieuses elle crée ensuite
des bijoux sur demande généralement on
est où dessinateur ou gemmologue on a on
a une spécialité moi il s'avère qui est
en toute petite TPE j'étais dessinatrice
mais j'avais aussi tout un bagage
scientifique parce que j'étais du lycée
de Versailles et donc ça m'a permis de
tout réunir et de faire quelque chose de
cohérent mais il n'empêche que c'est pas
fréquent Caroline ouvre sa maison de
joaillerie en 2004 une passion venue de
sa mère elle aussi gemmologue antiquaire
spécialiste des bijoux et meubles
anciens elle reprend ses études pour
obtenir son certificat de gemmologie
elle obtient en Angleterre en 2011 ce
sont des gros diplômes scientifiques
généralement un bacasse c'est
complètement demandé
moi j'ai pris l'option britannique
d'abord parce que la gymo toute la
géologie se fait en anglais aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus d'hégémonie française
comme elle l'était dans les années 70 5
ans d'études sont nécessaires pour
apprendre à connaître les pierres savoir
les évaluer connaître la classification
mais aussi la législation et la gestion
commerciale de ces produits de luxe le
géologue est aussi l'acheteur il est le
garant de ses produits moi je me déplace
beaucoup dans les pays asiatiques
puisqu'en termes de sécurité ce sont des
pays qui nous permettent de voyager et
d'acheter des pierres en toute
on est nombreux on a des dates
internationales et on y va il y a bal
aussi en Suisse à Givet moi parce que
c'est vraiment plus pour les grandes
maisons quand on achète une pierre on
évite de le faire seul parce qu'en fait
on avait décalages horaires on sait
jamais ce qui peut se passer donc on se
fait toujours secondé on est une dizaine
à être du même réseau et à ce second est
plus ou moins quatre fois par an
Caroline voyagent pour trouver ses
pierres le reste de son temps elle le
consacre à l'expertise ou à la
réparation de bijoux anciens
ici hop tout disparaît ce n'est pas de
l'or
des pièces inestimables elle ne les
garde jamais dans son atelier pour des
questions de sécurité la discrétion est
nécessaire lorsqu'il s'agit de parler
d'argent il faut pas aimer
obligatoirement l'argent parce qu'on en
manipule beaucoup mais il n'est pas à
nous moi quand on me quand on me confie
des bijoux ce sont pas les miens donc il
faut une
certaine
réserve par rapport à tout ça le monde
de la haute joaillerie et de la
gemmologie est un milieu très
confidentiel sur les 12000 personnes du
secteur seulement 4% travail sur les
perles et les pierres
et c'est la fin de notre émission je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivi je
vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine à la même heure pour un
nouveau numéro de philo très bonne
soirée à vous